this came about when I met Kevin I'd
been invited to be a mentor at a retreat
for extreme sports athletes what Kevin
would call action sports athletes what I
call extreme sports athletes and it was
a retreat and designed to inspire
athletes to use their platform for
social change and we were squidding my
film wasteland and at the back of my
mind was this idea extreme sports that's
a really interesting world and I don't
know what I make of it because when I
watch those sports I find myself being
very compelled my eyeballs are sucked
out of my head and I want to watch them
but I'm so worried about them athletes
so I happened to meet Kevin and
instantly was struck by him of course as
you've seen he just struck me as a
incredible charismatic star with an
incredible story now this was after the
crash this was Kevin's very first outing
after the crash a 2010 and kevin was
very early in his recovery he kept
reintroducing himself to me and he
couldn't watch my phone wasteland and he
was really early in his recovery and to
start with I thought my gosh what an
amazing young man but I didn't think of
making a film I guess for two reasons
partly it seemed like the story was over
and then as I observed Kevin I realized
that the story wasn't over at all the
story was about to get in fact extremely
interesting because I observed Kevin
wanting to get back and and keep up with
his colleagues who were all doing crazy
dangerous stuff around the place and and
I thought my gosh what is it to be have
this thing that you do taken away from
you and so suddenly and dramatically and
and is he going to dig deep what's going
to happen to him I wanted to find out
and you saw him those family scenes and
just everything they welcome Lucy and
the camera crew and everybody just in
and kind of really gave a very cool
perspective so I was so lucky you know
even something as big as having cameras
in at your Thanksgiving dinner you know
they just are so open and just welcoming
make Lucy feel like a part of the family
and I think that's really kind of what
allowed this you know to be you know
come across so amazingly and there was
only ever two or three of us if there's
if it's simple our record the sound
myself if it's a little more complicated
I'll get somebody better than me but I
really like being small and intimate
otherwise I just don't think it's as
effective and and I have lots of tricks
and tips I have lots of things like I
don't like to give people the
opportunity to cut I usually say don't
worry let's film everything and we can
figure out afterwards what to use and I
have tricks but I have to say my main
trick is being extremely picky about who
I work with and this family was
incredible as you've seen and I think
also they have a philosophy that if
there's a problem or a disability you
shouldn't be ashamed of it and it's good
to share it and they have this courage
and honesty that you can't no amount of
brilliant documentary directing is as
good as picking my dad had some of that
film at some of that footage from the
very early days and then growing up kind
of there was always a camera around me
and I'd always been filmed and so there
was a ton of footage and you know
luckily for me my family hadn't always
been filmed and they just open arms
welcome Lucy and the whole crew into our
family and allowed us to be filmed but
for me it was just normal because I've
been filmed my whole life's and luckily
for the movie we were able to get all
that footage talking to someone last
night and it's like the main thing for
me is that I'm still recovering and you
know I'm still fully in the middle of
this and it's so hard just cuz it's been
three and a half three and a half years
but still my brain is you know still so
much getting better and I'm still kind
of you know seeing changes and it's very
slow and it's kind of very hard but you
know that's the coolest part that it's
like right now I'm my brain is still
getting better and along with that I'm
doing announcing and then trying to do
some public speaking and then been
cruising around with this amazing movie
showing this and kind of letting people
see what Lucy you know put together so
I've been busy and life's been really
fun for me
it's different now because I'm not
competing anymore but it's still fun I
think Kevin's story dramatizes how high
the stakes are for these athletes and
what is going on in this world of
extreme sports that has only ever been
shown through these glamorous films that
only ever show how you know gorgeous and
snazzy it all is and we wanted to really
so truthfully share Kevin's experience
and his family's experience which is
surprisingly rare that you know there's
so many sports films but not something
like this that's been done before and I
think it does raise a lot of questions
about whether the conversation about
safety has kept pace with this thrilling
evolution in the sport in in in our
lifetimes I'd like to thank these guys
mom and dad and Dave Dave especially
coming oh they want sup come on up there
thank you guys